[Music]
members of the LGBTQ community were out
for billboard and The Hollywood
Reporter's Pride summit 2019 which
featured many from all facets of the
entertainment industry speaking to their
LGBTQ experiences and hopes for the
community including the cast of
groundbreaking series pose I saw that
each and every one of these women as
well as the men were a color whether
they be Latino latina black or up any
person of color I just knew that they
were of color and I was like well one I
have to be a part of it because of this
but also because of the human aspects
that they had and the breakdown they
showed every single thing that certain
cisgendered individuals get casted for
we had them to and I was like okay this
goes to show that we're being seen as
humans that's the first thing that
anyone should see us as is human right
we shouldn't be seen as anything other
than I mean yes we are trans yes we are
african-american and Latino and Latina
but we're much more than that
we are human Canadian duo Tegan and Sara
were also on a panel and spoke about how
they try to help and homophobia within
the music industry I mean ultimately I
think just it's not like any of us have
the answers on how to fix it but I think
we want to participate in trying to you
know basically disrupt and rebuild the
system and I do think that that is it
feels very much like that is what we're
trying to do as an industry I think we
are all trying to look at all of the
systemic problems that are still within
this you know in the music business and
talk about it many stars from the
popular reality competition series
RuPaul's Drag Race we're also at the
event I think it's great that on the
show exists and it has created this Lake
entire economy that
is like drag queens you know because
it's not just for the Queens it's the
people who are making us our nails and
our clothes and our hair and our jewelry
so like that entire economy also the
promoters who are giving us places to do
shows so it's an entire economy that has
blossomed out of that YouTube star Gigi
gorgeous who's been right here on 80
Canada pride you should probably check
it out if you haven't yet spoke about
fellow Canadian openly bisexual Lilly
Singh and why she'll never stop posting
to her YouTube channel whenever I see
like I mean Lilly who is a fellow
Canadian girl
I'm just got a late-night talk show
which is like maybe the most mainstream
thing ever and I'm so happy because
honestly I feel that youtubers a lot of
the time have more of a deeper
connection with their fans then you know
even like a Leonardo DiCaprio because
it's literally them turning on the
camera with whether they have a team or
not and literally just talking to the
camera and it's more of that genuine
connection so would you agree with Gigi
do you feel more connected to youtubers
than Hollywood celebrities do you think
there's still homophobia in mainstream
media are you excited for Lilly Singh's
upcoming talk show let me know in the
comments below and don't forget to
subscribe to ET Canada's YouTube page